i've been lucky enough on toe on the
podcast to get some people who have said
no to virtually every other place and
i'm not sure why and jim semivan said
that
there's this sentiment behind the scenes
that toe is
a quote-unquote scientific podcast and
if one wants to talk about the
phenomenon in some technical manner then
perhaps it's the place to go i don't
know if i buy that because well for
various reasons but
some people
for example on reddit have called it
distoster like there's disclosure like
somehow
yeah right right maybe i'll make a merch
item of that
so
that is cool
is that something that could happen i'm
not saying that that has happened but
does that occur is there a
behind-the-scenes kind of um discourse
about them and um you know who's good to
go on and who's good not to go on and
that type of thing for
people who um talk about things that
are like ufos and things like that is
that what you're asking yeah um
yeah
right i think so
and um i think that um
i mean we talked about this when we
talked about you know if we're talking
about something like ufos and the you
know if in fact ufos are say
extraterrestrial um
or
if in fact they are non-human
intelligence okay that we just have not
discovered yet because you know whales
have non-human intelligence and such we
know about them okay but if this is some
kind of new form of non-human
intelligence
that is able to travel our skies
and um this would be something that the
military would absolutely want to know
about and so that makes discussion of it
highly um
surveilled
okay
and
up for potential management therefore
podcasts um you'd have to assess use
your discernment and assess and vet you
know peoples whose people
or podcasters
um you know
what message are they putting out there
and do you want your work to align with
that message or not that kind of thing
so there's no i mean there's no real
kind of like um non-biased media even
podcasters have their biases so we so i
think that a lot of people who are at
least my colleagues who are working on
the topic of uaps and ufos generally are
academics or they're associated with
programs that have to do with academia
um or government programs and so they're
going to be pretty careful about where
they go to spread their information um
if they're people who've been doing this
for a very long period of time say like
jacques valet
um i think that his message is pretty
clear has been out there for a long time
so it can't be used or manipulated right
and i think that he's safe to go on
anybody's podcast frankly um but other
people whose work is maybe different
than valets and whose work has not been
out there for years um i think they have
to be pretty careful
if you were me what would you do to help
safeguard against being used for
disinformation
right so that's actually hard to do um i
think that you have to be pretty clear
in your questions and you have to be
pretty clear
in
your intentions a lot of times you can't
control the people you're you know who
you have on as a guest
and a lot of times you there are
unintended consequences of what you put
out there
um like that happens to me so i'll ha
i'll have said something and then it
will be used in in a completely
different way and there's really nothing
we could do about that crew so it's a
public sphere that you're putting this
message out
in and then what happens is that beyond
your own intentions those things then
get completely changed and used
i've actually written about this but um
not specifically for ufos but definitely
for religion
um
you know the uh the raid
you know the monk the immolating monk um
kwang duke i can't remember his full
name um but he's a vietnamese monk who
is or was
he was who emulated himself
um
you know during the vietnam war
or beli i believe maybe directly
afterwards well his image was then taken
up by this band called rage against the
machine and put on a cd cover of theirs
and then became the image kind of
came became
decontextualized from the actual reason
why this man actually did this was to
protest
um
suppression of buddhism by the
communists via the vietnamese government
and so um
so then people actually have tattoos of
it and about i'd say it was like maybe
12 years ago one of my students had a
tattoo
and i said you know i said the name of
the monk
and
he said he didn't even know
he just thought it was a cool image but
he had tattooed on his body so i guess
my point is this is that you know
that man did this
important act for a very specific reason
but
but nobody knows about it now but his
image is out there we all we've all seen
the image you see what i'm saying yeah
it reminds me of teenagers who have the
shirt that has the nirvana logo and even
says nirvana and then you play them teen
spirit or smells like teen spirit and
you say who sings this to it i don't
know i never heard this man before
pretty funny so the way that i try to
safeguard against is firstly i don't
think i can and secondly is with regard
to intent i hope that this is the case i
don't consider myself to be
well i'm i'm a selfish person but
hopefully this is the case where i'm
just an extremely curious person and
much like yourself much like researchers
in general and so i have many questions
and when it comes to a physics person
i'll just say i have a professor here
and it's like office hours and so i'm
just saying i don't understand this part
how did you get from here to here how
does this make sense with this and then
they try and explain it to me and where
i don't understand i ask questions and
so i do something similar with the ufo
guests where i'm simply asking questions
but then i also feel like that's a
cop-out if i was to
say hey i ask questions and then it's up
to the audience to quote unquote decide
i don't like that i think that when
people say that they're abdicating their
responsibility of putting out quality
information so i don't know how to solve
that
yeah i don't know if we can solve that
like i said look what happened to
uh the vietnamese bunks image